fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby my brother Pauly Shore who
I've known for 27 I think almost 28
years do I look chubby in this shirt or
are we good no that shirt you first of
all I appreciate that you you buttoned
it all the way up cholo style yeah right
and then but you're respectable you like
I have to change my shirt well yeah
because I came in I came in I came
rolled in with the T-shirt but this is a
big podcast I have to you know what I
mean although both the t-shirt and that
looks like you might have gotten them in
a thrift stores that's that's fair
because it's dull colors I'll just say
yes
dude the first time I remember Patty
Jenkins who's well let's first of all
yeah we want to put a shout out to
Brandon who can't be here oh Brandon
can't be here Brandon had an emergency
but everything is okay emergency was
that Polly show us on the podcast that's
right and I can't be seen with that
[__] guy I got a text and said it
said tell him tell Paulie I love the
[__] out of him so that was good he felt
really bad because he's so yeah he's
fine but everything happens for a while
for a reason dude no for a reason dude
everything has foreign
I just got back from Vietnam so I've
seen people like you recently
I understand but it's all part of the
East East Asia sort of it's East Asia so
it's all part of that same like Pad Thai
Noodle Express I don't know if that's
true he doesn't eat pad thai noodles
dude
we could order some Uber Eats and he can
[__] eat that [__] right now with
some [__] Pho and some goddamn tofu
it does you're being super provincial
that's good Embrace this guy what do you
want from me well you grew up in L.A
yeah I grew up around a cesspool of
[__] just filth you grew up so I grew
up for since I was three years at The
Comedy Store yeah so it's like you know
Pauly Shore was here I mean uh Mitzi
Shore is your mom she changed comedy in
some ways she did and the funniest thing
I ever saw and it was a lesson for me in
comedy and Patty Jenkins the great
director Wonder Woman Bob Dylan for a
second
she goes she goes do you see what he did
and Paulie got up on Mad TV
and told did a monologue that was true
and tragic and the funniest monologue we
probably ever had on Mad TV because he
talked about how you and your brother
got in a fight with the guy that was
dating your mom Mia Argus and he goes he
opens the monologues like this he goes
this is on national TV Paulie goes I'm
probably sure loser
and you went in and Patty I remember she
goes Brian do you see how he told the
truth it was tragedy but made it
hilarious that's why he's so good and I
learned a huge lesson in comedy from you
oh wow I'm serious yeah I never forgot
it wow so I don't know man you've always
been an original stamp
and now we're both old guys yeah that's
I find that I just turned 55 how old are
you I'm 56. okay so we're the same yeah
and I I I like I like that because
there's something about I love Brendan
but he's too young for us I was like
yeah he doesn't get a fuzzy feeling when
he sees me no you gotta fuzzy word yes
and then his pubic hair starts to stand
up no in recognition uh
oh God you can't do that dude his name
is Finn I know don't say it three times
though like that's because that would be
1950s racist so chin do you ever go to
the Korean spa you know what's funny
like all my friends go not all my
friends a few my friends go but I've
never been and they always say yeah
my friends are white and they go yeah no
I love to the Korean so I go all the
time Bobby Lee's spot we spot right no
it's a spot that no one really knows
it's actually a spot that's like kind of
in a cesspool part of Koreatown and
there's actually like hooker karaoke
like in a like so you know about that
karaoke world yeah yeah how crazy is
that yeah dude karaoke dude there's the
Korean spa and then like you walk in and
like all sudden these 11s bro they're
like leaving in this one room I'm like
holy [__] and I and there's a security
guy there I'm like what's that he goes
oh that's karaoke I'm like yeah right
but I guess they do karaoke and then
they do other things so you're singing
while you're [__] I don't know what
they do but it's just well obviously you
told me there were 11's now I'm
intrigued but I don't go in it yeah you
know I started leaving yeah I just see
them walk going in and out yeah yeah
but were you tempted no I did that in
Vietnam you did of course
do you have a lady right now you stayed
single forever yeah I'm still single no
kids no kids what did you ever want kids
um I do want a kid because I feel like I
can love a lot like I have a dog you
know what I mean so that's kind of like
an kid appetizer yes you know it's like
a you know what I mean you start a kiss
starter kit so I have that but then I
[__] see these horrible horrific you
know stories about kids yeah that become
you know I I have a joke on my ACT where
I say um I I say I want to have a kid
but I'm too I'm too young to have it or
no wait hey I say I'm too young to have
a kid and then that gets a laugh right
because I'm obviously old and then I say
uh I want to have a kid at 70 because 70
is the perfect age because if you have a
kid at 70 then like you can enjoy the
kid and they're beautiful twos threes
fours fives and when they turn a teen
and they [__] hate you they're vaping
you die you die and they're vaping you
know what I mean and they [__] want
to kill you and you're like sorry I'm on
hospice bro good luck in this life I
don't want to be a friends with my kid
at 40 anyways who wants to go to lunch
with their kid who's 40. that's like I'd
rather go to lunch with you that's so
funny but think about it from from one
to like 18 yeah they're cool and then
after that from one to fourteen there
you go my daughter's 14. oh wow could
not does not care about me like
literally right I go to see her I I
don't see her for like four days she's
too busy for me right and then I start
to freak out if I don't see my kids
right so I go uh I don't live they live
with their mom so I go but I see them
pretty much every day when I'm in town I
get along great with their mom so it's
all good so I go I see them and I'm like
and I see my daughter and she's like Hey
Dad and then she's just on her phone and
I'm like hey and then I go like this I
go teenager on your phone uh how about a
little something for for dad like hi hi
and she'll she'll that's she'll go
really seriously I'm a teenager be more
obvious yeah I'm a teenager right and
she's already annoyed at me and she goes
back to her phone yeah that's it so I
assume being a teenager is the bump in
the road of the T of the person's life
because whenever someone be becomes a
teenager that's when there's that bump
in the road but then after they're 23 24
8 29 then they kind of probably will
come back around well you think she'll
be coming back around like normally do
she's really intelligent I have a theory
on it
um I think when you're 14
there are physiological things that are
going on and you start feeling so deeply
you can't even handle it you ever know
you remember that remember how deeply
you felt from the age of really from
from for me from the from the age of 14
to [__] 40 but but really from the
age of 14 to
I don't know 20 was overwhelming first
of all in its confusion in Terror in
hormonally it's just like and then
you're angry at the world and you don't
know where to place your anger that
wasn't my upbringing but that was
everyone else's upgrade yeah famous
really I got but I would have had no
parental supervision no dude I never got
it well tell us about that because it's
so fascinating ever for you guys who
don't know Paulie's mom Mitzi Shore
essentially created what is now known as
the the world famous comedy store and
discovered everybody you can imagine you
know Jim Carrey I mean everybody the
list is so nuts and Paulie grew up
around the most famous comics of all
time you know Sam Kinison all those guys
and her and his mom was the Apex she was
the facilitator she was the owner she
was the one who chose who got up on The
Comedy Store and who didn't I remember
being passed by Mitzi in 2006 it was
it's a criminal moment was one of the
biggest moments in my comedy life and it
is in everybody's comedy it's
interesting because you know obviously
we're all very close with Joe Rogan and
and everyone has that same kind of
feeling and including Rogan yeah include
yeah yeah him and all you guys and and
you know and uh Coco Diaz and Ari and
all of you guys and yeah no um
it's I'm still I'm still um very
traumatized with my mom's passing it's
very hard for me to talk about it's hard
for me to be at the store it's the whole
thing is I mean that was one of the
reasons why I moved to Las Vegas because
it was it's very emotional for me there
because still absolutely when I walk in
there I feel like I'm walking into my
mom you know because everything there is
her her spirit so it's like but she
created it so where she put the picture
there she put you know the curtains the
whole you know the whole thing never
thought of that Paulie yeah so when I'm
there it's kind of like it's it's not
just I'm a comic I'm going on stage at
The Comedy Store yeah it's not like that
it's very yeah it's it's an emotional
and then when my dad died my sister died
yeah Sandy died yeah she died um she
died about three years ago she died the
same year my dad died how old was she
she was 65. Sandy was amazing [__] yeah
and your dad you were close to your dad
very close to my dad very close to my
dad but yet your parents
well my parents divorced when I was
three and then my mom you know she's ran
the store and my dad was off doing his
stand-up but he was still a great father
I'm sure yeah and you know he opened for
Elvis right yes I didn't know that until
very if you look at the Elvis movie
that's out now you see the billboard
Elvis and Sammy Shore so he yeah he um
my dad was was the oh triple triple OG I
mean triple triple oh yeah yeah like he
started the whole thing look at him yeah
so you grew up with a father who was a
stand-up comic and your mom there's a
there's a legend that you would be
crying in the crib and your mom would be
like let him cry yeah he'll he'll learn
how to had a bomb and deal with people
who knows she said she programmed me to
be a comedian it's on my album
um wow yeah my mom was you know and she
was a good mom despite the fact that she
wasn't there she was I wasn't there what
do you mean she was at The Comedy Store
she was physically at the commissary
doing the lineup and running the club
which was her real passion but she also
gave me to comedians You Know Jack
Perdue was a big babysitter Mike binder
was a big babysitter Argus Hamilton was
a big baby really yeah and these guys
all took care of me like for instance
like little league like they my mom
never went to one of my little league
games but she The Comedians took me to
My Little League games so then I would
play little league and I'd look over and
there'd be like all the comedians on the
side it's like a gangster it's like it's
like Goodfellas only comedy yeah
representing my mother and on the other
side would be my father and he'd be
there and since my dad was a comic he'd
always [__] around so he'd wear and I'm
not kidding he would [__] wear his
Speedos and he had a hair piece that was
all [__] up and then he put Banda
Soleil oil all over his body and would
yell at me like a gay man and he'd be
like hit the ball you little [__]
[__] hit it and he had to have his hair
piece in the comics all trying to [__]
the you know Beverly Hills housewives
and you got Bob Dylan sitting there too
what yeah because Bob Dylan's kid was on
my team that's why I wear these glasses
I wear these glasses because wait wait
so so what's his name uh Sam Dylan oh my
God so there's Jesse Dylan there's Jacob
Dylan there's Sam Dylan Sam Dylan was
the one who nobody knows correct so he
played right field on my on my team and
um oh my god dude yeah that's him oh I
don't know it's Sam Dylan somewhere
around there wow wow so Bob Dylan Bob
Dylan you would be Bob Dylan would be
sitting there and you'd be playing yeah
is there even any photos of Sam Dylan on
the internet probably not yeah it's
crazy
did you type in Sam Dylan Sam Dale and
Bob Dylan the son of Bob yeah I don't
know wow he's like the um yeah there he
is in that that shot with him is it here
possible no to the right hard right here
up there yeah there you go so he's one
of those kids
dude so you'd be your dad was but I went
to but I went to Beverly Hills High
School in the 80s yeah so it was [__]
like I mean where did you grow up I grew
up all over the world but I was we're in
the 80s where were you in the 80s I was
in uh dude how great is that that
Brandon's not here I know he would [__]
up this whole episode he'd be like hey
like what about the puss you know what I
mean look at my ear bro check out my ear
dude we got a party in Vegas that's a
great Brandon shop impersonation that's
a spot on it yeah okay good voice he's
cool he's actually very funny no but but
forget the fact that you love him like
I'm a I'm a comic and I like to see
people that are funny yeah and I was in
Vegas and he came to do a show at the
Wise Guys yeah and I I'd seen them at
the store here and there but I saw him
do a [__] headliner set and he killed
yeah and I was really happy for him well
we he just did uh Joe Rogan we did his
Joe's podcast fight companion and it
like I was talking to Joe Brennan was so
[__] funny right he was so funny and
I was like and Joe was like we gotta
start doing that more because he is he's
[__] some when he's on that dude it's
hilarious because it's you know everyone
that starts doing stand up late yeah you
can get [__] from guys like us yes you
know what I mean and like oh you know
like Dean Del Rey is a great example you
know when Dean decided to start doing
stand-up I'm like [__] this guy right
you know what I mean he's [__] 40
something all of a sudden he's doing
stand-up yeah and then in the Hostile
world yeah and I'm like oh now you want
to just stand up right and then I'm like
okay okay and then he got really good
and he's [__] hilarious yeah same
with Brendan yeah you know so it can be
done Kirk Fox is the same thing you know
Kirk Fox is a guy that started way late
he was writing right
yeah wait you were you were touching on
something before we got into this where
you said I was touching on Brandon's
crusty no but before that before that
you said something
like oh in the 80s yeah so I went to
high school I went to high school in
Massachusetts and then I went to college
in DC but talk to me about Beverly Hills
High School in the 80s all right let's
take a little break um guys real quick
uh as far as to hold is concerned um
that's a company that I was involved
with not anymore not because I don't
believe in the company not because I had
a falling out I love uh AG the founder
he's still the dear friend it's I still
believe in the company I'm gonna post
this video of Brian Shaw not being able
to pull them apart uh it's just that I
stopped being able to add value I just
didn't know where I was going to add
value anymore I was too busy and uh they
they were doing great things with the
company and I was just like I don't know
how I'm gonna add to this and I don't
have time to because I'm doing all these
other things so that's really what
happened
um uh so I divested from that but I'm
still a supporter and I still wear their
products because they're awesome and uh
so that's that's that's that's what I
wanted to say in case anybody had any
thoughts about that
um all right let's talk a little bit
about and by the way I'll be at the
comic strip get your tickets Edmonton
Alberta Thursday to Saturday Saturday
February 23-25 I'm Zanies March two to
four and then that's in Nashville I'm
then in New York New York Manhattan Sony
Hall March 11th one show only get your
tickets
um
briancallen.com West Nyack New York
Levity Live March 16th to 18. the list
goes on man I won't stop can't stop
um let's get into uh look sometimes you
need a talks sometimes there's a wedding
you can go to certain places where you
can rent a tux it always looks terrible
okay so here's the bottom line if it's a
special occasion you can actually get a
tux made for you you can have a custom
tux I'm talking about black tux okay it
makes it super easy to get on Trend top
quality guaranteed to fit tuxes without
ever leaving your house now here's how
it works take the black tux fit quiz
pick the style you want to rock and your
tux is delivered to your door in 10 days
before the day you need it that's plenty
of time to try it on and make sure it
wears well and if the fit's not right
you send the if the if because you send
it right back it's called the black tux
fit guarantee you can order a better
size within a day or two of receiving
receiving the less than grade fitting
one and they'll send you another the one
right away at no extra cost and if you
prefer an in-store experience the black
tux has showrooms across the country so
that's how it is I went and I had my tux
um measured
and uh I can't remember it was it was a
long time ago but uh you go in and I
think there's one in Beverly Hills or
something and and I needed to talk
because I've rented from uh other tux
places where you I actually gone to
places where you rent tuxes and it
always looks terrible so get a custom
fit one rent or buy by the way you can
also rent the black tux is the best
place to go when you need a tuxedo for a
wedding or a special night and right now
when you go to the blacktucks.com
fighter and use code fighter you'll save
10 percent so that's the black tux Tu X
t-h-e-b-l-a-c-k-t-u-x.com slash fighter
code fighter save 10
theblattux.com fighter code fighter get
some on it is a company I have been
promoting and using for I think probably
almost 10 years now maybe eight years
um and the thing I will talk about
tonight is today tonight I don't know
why I said that is Alpha Brain which is
their Flagship Alpha Brain started I
remember I remember when Joe Rogan got
into nootropics and he was talking about
uh nootropics and he was he was talking
about Alpha Brain which is something he
started he was putting the ingredients
on the web for people to like use it he
believed in it so much he was like if
you don't want to buy it here are the
ingredients get it on your own
um and he still uses it and some of the
most high functioning people I know use
it so Alpha Brain that's or there's a
reason Anna became so big it's because
they've sold over a million bottles so
try it see what you think it improves
memory and focus your cognitive
abilities okay give it a shot nootropics
on the newest science and uh they do
work so uh go to onnit.com
f-a-t-k on it.com com slash fatk and
that will get you ten percent off there
it is ten percent off so uh enjoy on
it.com slash f-a-t-k get some who'd you
go to high school with well David
Schwimmer was there yep so did you know
Cece horwich no okay she was my she was
my girlfriend in college but anyway no
um I don't know it was uh you know Lenny
Kravitz was there but he was older
Angelina Jolie was there but she was
younger
um Nicholas Cage was there he was a
little bit older
um so it was that kind of you know but
mostly was David Schwimmer when I was
there yeah you know what he was there
but it was just like Beverly Hills High
it was like a Molly ringwall movie Yes
you know what I mean it was just like um
Joy there's nothing but joy and fun and
high fives were you popular I was all
right you know but you just had a blast
yeah I was all right I did a lot of
different things I had a lot of a lot of
crazy [__] happen I have a friend of
mine named
um we used to go to this club called The
Odyssey which was a very famous kind of
teen club back in the 80s it was uh all
the kids from Pali went there Santa
Monica City College you know Manhattan
Beach like all the cool kids Beverly
they all went beautiful kids yeah they
went to uh to to the Odyssey it was an
underage club and my friend who was my
best friend he came from the bad part of
Beverly Hills you know the Horace Man
part there because there's there's
there's four different uh junior highs
in in Beverly Hills there's Horsemen
Beverly Vista Hawthorne El Rodeo and so
El Rodeo and Hawthorne were like the
upper echelon Beverly Vista and Horace
man were like lower yeah tracks so he
went there and I took him in me and my
mom took him in he is his life was
[__] up because his family was [__]
up my mom always took people in so he
took them took him I loved Misfits yeah
my mom my mom stray dogs my mom took
them in and and and and he was 14 years
old he'd sleep over and blah blah blah
long story short we used to go to this
club and the owner of the club was named
lb uh Lawrence Benjamin which stood for
little boys so basically this guy used
to run Coke and started working for him
on a scooter delivering Coke to all
these different people and then lb
molested
my best friend and then killed and shot
lb and shot him in the head whoa yeah
whoa and he went to prison how old was
it how old was he was 14. oh lb was in
his 40s he was 14 years old yeah and and
lb scumbag yeah and then your boy got a
gun shot him in the head yeah I mean I
don't want to break down the the drawing
out story on what happened
that's a badass little kid he was like
[__] this yeah and he's been out he's
doing great he's one of my close friends
he's still he's out he
for seven years
pointed to me about what Beverly was
like there was some heavy [__] and there
was also some awesome [__]
um uh [__] my prom was amazing uh you
know every year I was a different thing
one year I'm a surfer next year I'm a
mod next year I'm a break dancer a comic
you know I was doing like I was I would
get into different things and I was very
into I mean there's it's all in my
one-man show so I have a one-man show
that I've been been running for a bit
it's called stick with the dancing I've
done it at the store I've done it all
over and it's stories of my childhood
and it's basically all the stuff you're
asking me now a lot of it's in that well
somebody who grew up who grew up with
comedy royalty and and and made his own
stamp in the comedy world and continues
to do you like do you like the state of
Comedy now what do you think remember
because back in the day in the 80s I was
thinking as you're talking you could get
away with so much
you know and maybe that's just Nostalgia
but do you think that um do you think
things are different do you think
they're better now what do you think
you know there's the the world has
shifted and we all have to be sensitive
to the shift and we have to I I think
for me I just have to I have to kind of
talk I worry about myself I like to go
to the edge I just don't go over the
edge you know I've always been that
comic yeah you know I've always been the
guy that [__] that like for instance
when I did a movie called adopted where
I go to Africa to adopt a black baby
like I really went over there and I
really did this whole thing but I went
to the edge but I did it's kind of
racist the movie's a little bit a little
bit harsh but it's not over over yeah so
it's like right to the so that's my
style whether there's the shift in the
in the world or not but um yeah you have
to be you know unfortunately more
sensitive because everyone's got a phone
and everyone can [__] with people yeah
and um that's what I liked about Vietnam
you know when I was just there a couple
weeks ago I was there I felt like I
could do and say anything why'd you go
there it's my birthday really yeah and
what did you think it was really it was
cool you know you know
um it was just again you know I don't
want to say I'm famous but people know
me whenever I walk into a restaurant
wherever I walk around people are like
there's Bali Shore so even in Vietnam no
not there that's what I was saying all
right that's what I was saying it was
that was the number one thing that I
really enjoyed was just to be able to
walk in a place and not have one say
weasel or not that I don't it's kind of
exhausting because Zach Galifianakis in
the height of his Fame when we're doing
hangover too oh my God he would walk
around Thailand yeah and he would just
walk and I was like what are you doing
he goes well I I can walk around 14 year
old boys aren't chasing me down the
street you know and and it was such a
relief it was kind of like this respite
where he could just kind of go somewhere
and just be anonymous yeah so so so I
enjoyed that part of it and then I'm
obsessed with Asians and I've always
been obsessed because of my mom because
my mom always had Asians working at The
Comedy Store in the bar sexually or or
no just I like them okay no it's not a
sex thing I just I just like Asians I I
think they're awesome yeah so um in
general yeah in general yeah I get
excited yeah and I see is that so I said
Chin Chin I'm like oh there's my friends
please call him oh you can't say it
twice well I feel like shin chin is
super it's a little bit Bobby Leo says
that Chin Chin yeah but Bobby Lee's
Korean I know but still so Bobby's
allowed to it's all good no I'm kidding
uh you know what I'm saying so so I was
raised at the comedy store around Asians
all the bar managers all their my my
Guardians my Guardians were Asians yeah
they were but this is way before you
yeah this is when I'm this little but
still yeah and even in the early 2000s a
lot of the guys behind the bar were
Asian
there was the people that ran The Comedy
Store when we were kids in the in the
70s uh SUNY and Ted so so Ted was the
bar manager at The Comedy Store and SUNY
was married to Ted and they lived at my
mom's house so SUNY would make me like
hot pepper beef and tupperware and a wok
and all that [__] in her room she had a
little Bunsen burner in her room so I'd
go in there and get sticky rice and we'd
just sit around and she'd make me she'd
make me um you know my lunch for school
so I'd go to school with hot pepper beef
and tupperware you know what I mean it
was [__] awesome and bows and [__]
yeah you know what I mean please stop
dropping [__]
but then you got how old were you when
you got famous
um probably in 2021 like God yeah like
that time yeah yeah what a time to be
famous I remember when you were dating
Savannah yeah and she was like for us
like she was the hottest porn star of
all time I think she killed herself
unfortunately yeah yeah
um but you just you ran it hard in the
in every every 20 year old wanted to
live your life like you were always with
the hottest girls on the planet
um yeah that's her yeah yeah she was
something else yeah she was um
my mom loved her yeah I go mom she does
porn she sucks dick for a living I know
she's great
fantastic she should be a comedian that
was when porn was still so subversive
but there were Superstars like her you
know yeah no she was you know I took
care of her you know I I really took
care of it you guys date on and off for
I don't know a couple years to three
years but when she killed herself we
weren't dating we had broken up at least
a year prior
yeah of course she was just you know she
was doing a lot of drugs
um her looks were fading she was sick of
being Savannah she wanted to be Shannon
and um she had a stalker after her she
owed the IRS like lots of money and you
know her whole world was crumbling and
you know what's really sad about the
whole thing she was [__] 23 bro
23 when she killed her Christ do you
believe how young that is Kennison died
at 38. that's so I mean dude we're in
our 50s bro I know and it's [__]
insane well I always say if If I Die
Tomorrow People go it was a good run 56
nobody Mourns me nobody my kids but but
everybody else is like 58 [__] did it
what do you have what do you want you
got lucky yeah and I would be I would be
I think about that all the time I feel
like everything after this is gravey
I've experienced everything I've done
everything and and you know if if I go I
just I just worry about my kids and and
their mothers yeah yeah well you're
right I mean you know if you I have a
thing where I said uh if you make it to
80 you've won 100 You've Won after 80.
and um and you start to you start to um
you know feel that more when you're in
your 50s you kind of feel like you know
I think our biggest currency is time
yeah you know what I mean our biggest
currency is time you know I was driving
over here from West Hollywood that's a
far drive you know what I mean that's an
hour yeah it is you know what I mean but
I said I love you you know what I mean
I've always loved you thank you you know
what I mean I've always loved you and
I've always thought you were a great
comic and [__] funny and awesome I'm
like that's my boy Brian thank you you
know what I mean so he's a lot to me
yeah I'm gonna I'm coming out for him
and because you know we don't see each
other ever I know you know none of us do
everyone's in our own own world now and
everyone's kind of like in our own again
it's funny because you have these people
in your life I've known you a long time
but I wouldn't see you allowed to hang
out but I got such a warm fuzzy feeling
when I saw you I was like yeah I was
like this my boy you know there's
something about that time that you spend
you know with people for a long time but
you're also very funny thank you you
know what I mean you're very funny and
you're a very good guy and I've always
enjoyed your stuff and I've always like
you're a whack-o like me yeah you know
what I mean and um and I'm happy for you
so well I I just want I don't want any
regrets when I die and I don't want any
unfinished business and I don't want to
think that I did anything that I
couldn't live down you know you you have
the other thing you have when you're
older is not just time but truth you
better you better live your life as
truthfully as you possibly can because
you will not get away with anything
other than that you just won't man so
sometimes I like to do the things that
like I kind of go what am I actually
supposed to do
you know or you know what I do sometimes
like I woke up with anxiety the other
day I was just like in the middle of the
night I worry about stupid [__] I do too
right we all I do too and then I looked
up and I was like I am the the I'm not
gonna be anxious the guy in the movie
that I admire he just decides he's not
that life's a [__] war or maybe a
battle or there are challenges and I'll
meet him halfway every time it's like my
favorite sayings there's a guy a really
tough guy one time and he had two broke
two black eyes and he fought a guy named
Tiny who was a giant and uh giant guy
giant huge yeah from The Comedy Store no
no no no no this guy was a big black
this guy was a feared guy in West
Virginia like a giant redneck who was a
lumberjack I fought everybody my buddy
fought him okay and and I said and the
guy said yeah and the guy just came
right at Tony and I said what'd you do
and Tony looked up and he goes I met him
halfway
and I was like that's the coolest thing
I've ever heard in my [__] life I
hope you see made him halfway what does
that mean in other words you come at me
full speed and you're 300 pounds I'll
meet you halfway
I'm gonna get out of my chair and I'm
coming at you too like that's a skin
instead of being like bro what the [__]
up he just went and came at him on my
Tombstone may it say he met him halfway
I don't know if that'll be the case but
I love talking matcha with you you're
like this uh-huh cool whatever well you
do that Taekwondo [__] you do all that
right all that stuff that's great which
is always I was watching I was watching
Joe alive again very proud of him very
happy for him I don't see him a lot yeah
and um you know I don't get to see him
he's so in his own you know he's out
there and and
um you know he starts talking about
anxiety you know I think we all kind of
experience it now more than when we were
younger for some reason when we were
younger we used to take naps you know
what I mean and now like a day yeah and
also he would just you're more in your
body you're not feeling age you're not
dying one body part at a time either you
know but I just think it's the way of
the world now if there's more [__]
there's I mean everyone's got these
things and in the news and everyone's
just like you know what I mean and it's
sensitive it's more sensitive now than
it was you know not everyone's trying to
[__] everyone you know like it was back
then but when we were younger you'd take
naps in the middle of the day it'd be
sunny out you just like
and now you take a nap you got to have
the thing shut you got a tired thing you
got to take a [__] Ambien you gotta
like all this [__] stuff and if you
hear a little thing you're like oh shut
that thing there you know what I mean
like what the [__] happened to us but
what Joe is saying which I think is true
is a fitness you know working out you're
saying you you know you do a lot of this
stuff it probably really helps it does
with this it does and that's why I go to
the gym too all the time it's not for
this it's for this and and I really like
you know all that stuff he pushes on
that because it's true you know
um because when you do what's hard yeah
I find like when I do Hard Exercise and
I'm consistent with it I feel braver and
I feel stronger that's why I like
fighting like it's why I would box or
you know do a little Jiu Jitsu I just I
just it's not it makes me feel I don't
know it makes me feel like I'm
contending with life in an honest and
objective way like I want to do what's
difficult and feel it sometimes I take a
cold shower like today I just got in the
water it was I worked out super hard and
then I got in the water and it was my my
wife was like what are you doing because
she could hear me because it was so cold
yeah but I like I like the pain
sometimes like I'm like I'm gonna do
this I don't want to do it and I'm not
going to negotiate with myself I don't
know bring Seneca the great philosopher
he used to sleep on the ground like two
days of the week of the of the month wow
he'd sleep on the ground in the cold
ground with nothing but water bread and
a blanket over his body it was
uncomfortable just to remind him that
there's nothing to be afraid of like no
matter what they do to you you're you're
okay I like that I like conditioning
myself
I thought Seneca was a sleep medication
but you know that'd be a good hand it's
a good name
you're crazy dude can I put some
Vaseline on his eyes why why because
he's a boxer and I put him in a ring oh
him yeah what
he's my fighter I'm a fighter in the
kids
you're speaking like a like a samurai
like a Japanese American not Korean but
yeah
yeah I'm definitely becoming more my
father as I get older as far as my stick
like but Mike binder opened for me
recently I don't know Mike and uh there
you go I'm feeling like my father on
stage now he goes that's good your dad
was awesome who are your favorite Comics
who are the ones that blew your mind who
are the ones that you are most
influenced by
well there was guys that no one's ever
heard of you know like Lenny Schultz I
know do you know him yeah Lenny Schultz
uh he was he was the the best
um because I never know who had any
shows he start at the store I remember
um yeah yep
um who else uh red fox I love red fox
um I loved [__] who was out Michael
Keaton Michael that's great people don't
realize he was a [__] great comic oh
my God was he at the comic store yes no
in the 70s yeah wow yeah Michael Keaton
remember he would read the Bazooka Joe
thing where he just he'd read the
Bazooka joke comic and it would just go
on and on he was yeah he was yeah he's
great so smart [__] I forgot he did
stand up dude so great
and then you know you got guys like Dave
Tyree
remember Dave Tyree [__] dude it's so
funny dude he was like Richard Pryor
funny but he never made it yeah you know
um
a lot of guys yeah put Dave Tyree
African-American comedian I don't know
there he is right that's him oh yeah
this guy was [__] fun wow
dude what happened all these guys did so
much coke dude that's the problem like
all these that's a career stopper yeah
Dave Tyree was great oh there's Paul
Mooney yeah Alan Stevens Alan Steven was
very funny Alan Stevens the only comic
that I've ever seen like do a bump of
coke and then go right to sleep
[Music]
and then you'll be like all right I'm
going to sleep I'm like okay you know
what's really funny Angel Salazar was
really oh yeah he was really what a
character was what was um he was great
is he still alive Angel yeah what's he
up to he's just touring I think he lives
in uh Miami
um but he's he was a really funny guy
yeah remember shake it out but these are
the guys that raised me dude damn do you
stay in touch sometimes yeah wow Angel
Salazar I I am Lois Bromfield was
[__] hilarious remember her no Lois
Bromfield She's a Lesbian comedian she
was my babysitter she took care of me
she was very funny man it's a real
personality type I think my son's gonna
be a comic my son oh yeah my son has all
the all the liabilities required for a
comic like ADHD you know uh sensitive
but but funny as [__] aware of his
surroundings afraid of his surrounding
well it's definitely something you're
born with like I have two brothers that
aren't Comedians and my sister wasn't a
comedian so um for me I was like a kid
when I was at the store yeah it was just
like like this they weren't like that
yeah you know what I mean so um it is
it's a really interesting mix it's also
like a it's a small fraternity of people
that can actually make anybody laugh
anywhere for an hour you know what I'm
saying like it's it's there are a lot of
comics now who do comedy but they're
they you got 10 minutes like relax you
know but like I'm talking about people
who have done this for so long and
stayed relevant that that's a that's a
small group of people yeah
you know
it's a really small group and people
weren't making money when you and I were
coming up people didn't make the kind of
money they do now because of social
media you know I don't know what it is I
think Netflix has a lot to in these
podcasts they think with Bert Kreischer
and Tom Segura I mean I mean you can't
hear I mean just like [__] nuts right
now I mean it's like I mean when we were
growing up you know there's maybe four
three or four guys that sold out Madison
Square Garden yeah maybe now there's
like 30. yes you know what I mean so but
also just like you can just curate a
following it used to be you would go
into a town you'd have to rely on local
media radio you didn't know who yeah you
had to do morning radio and you didn't
know who's gonna show up it wasn't like
fans it was people who like comedy who
decided to come in I remember doing
shows in um say Houston Texas
and uh I would I would ask the owner or
the agent would ask the owner where
tickets like they're like oh every
Show's half sold out you know it's like
half half half and then you go on the
morning radio show Stevens and Pruitt in
[__] Houston yeah well that was in
that oh that was that was in Philly
wasn't it no those are Philly guys those
are big guys too yeah so Steven's in
Pruitt if you I don't know that was
Houston okay Houston you know and these
guys that used to have the morning shows
you'd sell out because yeah such a one
thing boom and it was packed you do one
radio you knew and the thing is you knew
you were gonna sell out if you did that
morning radio period you weren't
thinking like oh man yes you know now
that doesn't exist anymore there's no
radio anymore right isn't it weird I
like it because I don't have to wake up
early yeah I [__] hate that [__] that
was the [__] worst especially jet lag
could be like three o'clock your time oh
yeah no it was the [__] worst but you
had to do it and then you get dragged
around they pick you up the owner or
whatever and they pick you up in that
[__] car and it's always a shitty car
did you ever do Sanford and Son with
Craig of course oh dude yeah I mean
that's a whole other podcast it's a
whole lot of other podcast yeah these
guys are [__] cokehead [__] uh
just I mean yeah I mean this was this is
where Eddie Griffin started this was you
know Kansas City back in the day and
these guys would you know I mean hey
brother you know and all that [__] well
Kansas City was where one of the Jazz
hubs of the world like Kansas City was
where it was kind of like the Gateway to
the West and so there there was a there
was a huge Underground Music Scene that
was incredibly Innovative in in Kansas
City so yeah yeah and they got good
[__] ribs [__] that's good that
[__] barbecue [__] red
Korean accent no that's a black thing oh
I don't know I'm just saying it's black
now we're switching it up [__] that's
good black people like me I'm good I'm
not gonna get [__] with black people
no that's that's a 90s black guy
okay I'm a 90s comic
do you follow any kind of diet
do I what do you follow a diet
like if I see it on the street just
followed it around just follow it yeah
um no I've always I've always kind of
taken care of myself with the food you
know I don't
you know yeah I don't go crazy
I don't go crazy you know
I mean I saw you in silver like we were
eating at the uh what was it uh uh Thai
place man no dude the [__] place
where it looks like you're an old New
York City oh um Stella right Cafe Stella
I love that place bro I haven't been
there in so long I know how great was
that remember when I saw you there one
of my favorite restaurants I always
forget it it's it's literally yeah it's
like a French Bistro yeah you feel like
you are you're in the village or you're
in Paris yeah amazing yeah I had a seven
year run in Silver Lake did you I lived
there for seven years it was [__]
awesome it was awesome and then I moved
to Vegas or no and then covet hit and I
I no covet hit and I moved to Hawaii
so I lived in Maui for a while wow
during covid which was [__] awesome
you have a place there I don't no I just
stayed there I got a condo and I stayed
there on a golf course that's they
didn't do stand up you just hung out
yeah it was covered everything was shut
down I was the only like
you know a person from the mainland
there do you play golf no I don't I
don't play golf absolutely not but I was
there during covert and then when I was
there
then I saw La was burning yeah to covet
and you know and the riots and the whole
thing it was [__] bad yeah and I'm
like I'm not going back to LA and I just
all my parents my parents had died and
all this [__] I'm like I go I'm [__]
exhausted I go I want to be around Joy
so I said Vegas
so then I moved to Las Vegas about two
and a half years ago and I lived next
door to Nicholas Gage oh my God so he's
my neighbor I'm the normal one next in
that [__] relationship yeah you know
what I mean we go out and it's like I'm
like you know I'm like looking at him
going oh [__] like this guy's you know
what I mean because he still lives he
lives in Vegas yeah dude what the [__]
is he living in Vegas for he's been
there 20 years what yeah dude why he
wanted to get away
he dislikes Vegas he likes the Nostalgia
you know Vegas has got the Nostalgia
Sinatra and [__] does he still like
the under tapestry of Vegas yeah yeah he
goes to like those old school Vegas
restaurants and you know and we you know
what I mean yeah
he's 59 I think yeah yeah I mean I loved
him in this last movie yeah unbearable
weight of
um uh Limitless Talent or whatever it's
called he's so good in that yeah he's he
doesn't he doesn't stop working massive
Talent yeah you know him well then huh
um we became close in the last year
um he did go to Beverly so there's that
kind of you know Jim Carrey used to
bring him around to The Comedy Store a
lot really yeah because him and Jim were
very very close so I'd met him you know
throughout the years
you stay in touch with Carrie
not really not really he seems like he's
unhappy
yeah I don't I don't know yes like you
know where he's like I'm gonna be off
Twitter and I'm not gonna do this and
yeah like okay Jim
you know what I mean like he seems like
he's
mad at the world in a way he seems like
a great person I know somebody who um
who created his show
um that last show he did called Jim
Carrey dying or whatever it was or
oh the one about the story you mean yeah
what was this TV show he did dying up
here yeah maybe it was dying up here I
don't know what it was but so so um but
the he said like the creator of the show
knew him really well and he said I said
what's he like he goes he's a great guy
he's a sweetheart he's just he's
probably gets he probably gets a little
bit more down than he should you know
it's like it's hard we're all mental
patients yes you're a mental patient I'm
a mental patient Jim's a mental patient
we're all a [__] mess yes you know
what I mean and and we're on the outside
it doesn't change that no we're on the
outside we're Outsiders you know what I
mean and that's what makes us
funny yeah you know what I mean and Jim
is genius genius I mean [__] genius
in so many levels so you know he can go
through whatever he he can go through
now he lives in Maui oh he does that's
where he lives and everybody gets the
[__] out of L.A and he's just uh yeah
he's just said I'm moving back actually
I'm actually giving my 30-day notice
today to my the owner of the house in
Vegas why are you moving back
it's Vegas I feel like I'm um I feel
like I'm secluded out there or isolate
it's the word from the entertainment
business yeah you know I'm I'm in the
entertainment business so I need to be
around people in the entertainment
business for instance if I go to
Starbucks in Vegas no one around there
is in the entertainment business if I go
to Starbucks in West Hollywood everyone
so I gotta be around that well what do
you want what do you want to do because
I love I love people I love the
mentality of people in the entertainment
business you know if I'm gonna if I'm
gonna do anything I mean
of just finding assistance you know what
I mean people you got to get people that
are in the business if you I don't know
I just I just you know I uh do you want
do you want to keep doing movies do you
want to start writing what do you want
to do you want to keep doing stand-up I
mean what are your goals like when
you're 75 what conversation is this
I love acting that's my biggest number
one thing you know I love acting it's
like for instance Brendan Fraser you
know who's a dear friend of mine from
Encino Man and blah blah blah like
yeah he's awesome and he's so talented
he's a sweetheart he got another shot
as an actor you know what I mean and
look what look what happens so for me
you know when I sell out my shows on the
road I'm not selling out because of my
podcast or my Netflix special or you
know something I did on YouTube I'm
selling out because all my films
that's why I sell out you know I have a
great audience out there that loves you
know 25 years later loves all my movies
and you know I've got them like this
because my movies got them like that
same thing with my MTV show you know
when I was on MTV that's where America
was introduced to me and and that's this
thing here it's a my shows at least this
is my feeling it's more of an experience
rather than like oh that guy was funny
you know there's a connection like my
autograph line where I sit in the back I
always take pictures and I always take
um uh uh photos and all that pictures
photos whatever with all everyone and
the stuff they say to me makes me cry
wow yeah you're a part of their history
makes me cry and that's why I keep going
yeah you know I connected this so I miss
acting you are you're a part of that
when you say you miss acting what was
the last big movie you did and did you
know it was your like because you had
this precipitous rise like all actors
and you're the most relevant guy and
then because of the way the business is
stocks yeah when did that happen
when did that when did it well when did
you yeah when did it start slowing down
well when I fired everyone on my team
you did yeah
tell my agent my managers all that stuff
after I had my run I was like I needed a
break
you know I needed to be alone it's so
funny you stopping and everybody's like
see you everybody forgets about you in
America yeah no I I I I just I needed a
break I needed to be alone I needed to
connect with people I was so famous and
I was so big that I lost the connection
so when I purpose not purposely but when
I kind of put myself back out on the
streets that's when I think I became a
better comic wow you know when I was
more connected because I wasn't on a
pedestal like oh there's the guy from
his movies there's mitzi's kid there's
the how many movies did you do at the
height of your it was like I did like I
think there was like six or seven big
movies yeah but also I did guest house
which came out two years ago which was a
big hit for me for Lionsgate because
that's the star I'm the star of that I
play the guy in the guest house and that
did well really well that's awesome yeah
and this is uh that's awesome yeah this
is my movie so everyone's in it Eric
Griffin's in it Bobby Lee's I love Eric
and I love Bobby yeah
Bobby's in it wow but this did really
well for me this was a rated our comedy
and it was on it's on Netflix right now
wow and um it did huge for me it was
like the one of the number one streaming
movies like two years ago all over and
then I'm the voice of Pinocchio that
just came out yeah yeah European okay I
play Pinocchio yeah bro you're killing
me yeah no no I've been doing a lot yeah
that's amazing yeah that's me I'm the
voice oh my god dude yeah I didn't I do
a lot of voiceovers mostly for Lionsgate
yeah oh my God but you know I think he
did a lot of voiceovers yeah a lot a lot
I've done a lot there's a Give me the
give me the Pinocchio voice father I
came to be on my own I had the whole
world to see I made him gay and it went
crazy I made him gay no if you look at
if you if you type in yo if you type in
uh Pinocchio uh polish chore viral video
or Rolling Stone or whatever you know
you could see like Rolling Stone or
something but but can we play this or no
we'll we'll see yeah you can play it
right there see yeah Suffocation poly
short sucks there you go
how polisher accidentally became
lgbtq icon on Tick Tock oh my God is the
one here yeah that's it father when can
I leave to be on my own I've got the
whole world to see
oh my God yeah I made him gay I got the
whole in the game and the gay people
went crazy they're like finally
Pinocchio's gay but the funny thing is
is I Didn't Do It purposely
I didn't go I'm gonna make Pinocchio gay
right it was like yo I'm this is how I
see the character which is kind of a
voice kind of a naive kind of guy yes
yes but there's a sing song to it yeah
but that's kind of what you've done like
it's like Christopher Walken when he was
younger right but you see you've done
voiceovers you know beep beep beep and
you come in yeah so I have I I don't
want to say I'm good at it but I know I
got I've been doing it for so long I was
the voice of goof uh in the movie of the
Goofy movie Goofy Movie I play the yeah
in all of those Goofy movies
yeah yeah leaning tower of cheese that's
a big how did Pinocchio do well it's a
big movie yeah yeah yeah yeah
so also there's a big trip that just
came out that's me right there
oh my God yeah
leaning tower of sheep I had no idea I
don't do any voiceover
yeah I love voiceovers it's fun I bang
them out too great way to make money I
can bang them out you know like because
you you know you you dress in your
pajamas yeah and you just go and [__]
knock them out yeah and you got a
director there who's awesome and you got
the editors awesome you go and then you
got this you got the uh um you know the
thing up there and you got the voice and
I did cars I think and I did um what's
the other one I did about planes but I
might get rid of that I was just doing
that I was just making noises
Jesus that's it and they'd be like all
right go try that again a little bit
more like a little bit louder
you know yeah but but when you say like
oh you're doing this dude I had no idea
like at the end of the day our business
is not about this it's about doing yeah
it is you know what I mean it's just
about doing and the only reason why we
do this is because we love it
that's it and if you can get paid and
you can you know be you know do what
Brandon's doing or or all you know or
all these guys where you get an
opportunity then that's even better then
your stock goes up but you know the
stuff that we're doing on YouTube the
stuff that we're doing on Instagram and
all that stuff it's the same thing it's
just at a smaller level at the end of
the day it's about doing it's not like
oh the crowd's sold out like who gives a
[__] right you can go on the or in front
of 40 people about doing I've always
said that I would I do this for free
right and some of the best uh some of
the best sets I've ever had most
satisfying we're in the OR of The Comedy
Store at you know 11 30 at night with a
bunch of comics in the back and for the
people but you're trying stuff out it
works for the first time whatever
happens you know and you know and people
put down people put down this time The
Tick Tock time and the Instagram time
and all that stuff like and I get excuse
me I get it but at the end of the day
it's give us a pla it gives us a
platform besides stand up to do whatever
it is that you want to do look at your
podcast you have a big podcast you could
have done this with Warner Brothers or
never or would have to give them all the
money too it was you know it's like
you're right this is but you create this
like you created this this is a this is
your show yeah and that's the positive
part of what's going on now because you
get us old guys in there that are like
oh it was so much better when you could
just go on audition and and I love that
too I hated it I loved it for me it was
like you know it's true that if you've
got a TV show it meant you could buy a
house if it went but it was like there
was so there were a lot fewer Outlets
yeah but that's what I liked because
more people would be focused on it let
me tell you something the thing that's
[__] up and like and then there's
negative [__] about it the the big
negative thing to me is that everyone is
a star now everybody everyone every
single person has got their own [__]
TV show so the problem is when Leo comes
on or Spielberg or Tom Hanks and this is
their you know their their movie or
their thing people are like okay great
anyways oh my God look at my likes oh
wait look at this video this cat fell
out of a tree yeah that's great Leo
anyways oh my God let me put a filter on
my thing and that's the thing that's
[__] up I know and then we're in the
movie theater they can watch it on you
know their big screen TV and what
happens is it's all atomized in the
tension your attention is yeah and I
remember I think we lose something as a
society when people everybody would go
see the Raiders of the Lost Ark and we
would all talk period we don't talk
about it and we all go to the movie
theaters when when it was the new Batman
with Jack Nicholson he was playing a
joker we all went oh my God everybody
talked about that for a year and and
when David Blaine would do a magic uh
thing on ABC and he was levitating all
of us would talk about it was like it
was it's it focused that's why it was
better back then yeah that's right there
was an intimacy to that because we all
spoke the same time and also there was
there's also the Hollywood dream that to
me is vanished because the old Hollywood
dream was come out to LA come to New
York work your way up
you get you know what I mean and now
it's like you can do it in Iowa you can
do it in France you could do it and it's
just there's no there's no Focus too
much white noise there's but there's no
focused attention right he's like when
they always talk about this with Europe
when when Nietzsche said God is dead in
Europe it meant Europe was no longer a
Christian Nation nobody there was there
wasn't a focal point on what truth was
truth was dissipated there was science
there was all this stuff and all of a
sudden people just were finding their
own truths and they found their own
truths in communism fascism you know
capitalism they're all different kinds
of truths and that that creates disunity
it doesn't unify people and that comes
with its own challenges like [__]
Civil War
civil unrest they've been talking about
that now yeah but civil unrest
everybody's a privileged American so
let's all come except for chin except
for Chad just say his name once
otherwise it's what race racist not not
good
yeah
that's great
if you can [__] you can get away with
[__] yeah tell us love it's all love you
know of course of course yeah yeah
that's cool dude not cool dude but let's
talk about Joe yeah Joe Rogan amazing I
know
so happy for him well you know we had to
talk um yeah yesterday and he was like I
love doing that fight companion because
it's my old friends in the same room and
I moved to Austin I don't get enough of
that yeah you know a lot of it is just
there's something about Fame that's
super isolating too like that kind of
thing where you're you get so famous
that you have to kind of build a wall
around yourself because otherwise it's
unmanageable
and so I think that part of him moving
out there there's a price for everything
you know and it's not the hangs at the
store it's not the hang you know that
but he's creating his own world in
Austin
I think what he's doing is beautiful and
I'm very proud of him you know just as
one of his peers from a distance what
he's doing there building the club
creating it from what I understand like
my mom's you know which is the
development of comics and you got Adam
out there and Curtis yeah and you know
again you know whether you know he's
isolated not isolated just like you said
there's good and bad in everything we do
it doesn't matter I mean look at
Chappelle or you know the guy came on
stage and hit him or try to hit him it's
like
you know but I'm happy for him and I'm
happy he's doing so well I started to
talk about him on CNN and [__] we have
it and then he fires back and CNN
crumbles but I I talk about power but I
I watched his last uh I watched his one
hour recently in shows yeah yeah he I
was in Salt Lake and he was like I was
up in Park City and he goes I'm at Salt
Lake playing for 14 000 people you got
to come down and see what this is like
and he's he's surrounded by 14 000
people
dude I I watched him he's you don't get
more famous and so then what happens is
you get wealthy and and you can relax if
you want nobody
he's still just as intense as he always
has been and his one hour was so
inspiring because it was so good so
dangerous so full of [__] irreverent
material and I was like this
[__] is is has not allowed the
public embrace the wealth all of it to
influence his his to dull his instrument
even a [__] little bit he's he's
doing [__] that he's doing stuff with
the same kind of power he used remember
when he killed the room like back when
he was younger like the comedy story
just be like he'd come off like he'd
swept through two shirts he's doing that
[__] again yeah and I'd just be like how
are you doing that when you're this High
how are you doing that on marijuana it's
like that guy who [__] does it a a
line of blow and goes to sleep joking
joking smoke heavy weed and be more
intense wow so I don't know yeah well
he's he's hit that nerve yeah you know
and he's in that in that space and he's
in that that
um that van mean it's the same guy that
he is on the podcast you know where he
just kind of cuts through it and it's
the same thing with the stand-up yeah I
saw him in um at the MGM do a show with
Chappelle and it was the same I was so
proud of him I'd give him a hug I said
you know I said my mom would be really
proud of you you really are a real comic
now yeah because again for a while the
you know Fear Factor thing and and the
UFC thing but he's
he's [__] like a real comic so again
I'm really happy for you well comedy's
always been his number one yeah but
comedy he had he always had great
reverence for it he still does he still
gets nervous but he's gotten better yeah
he's got something better I know you
know that's what's amazing yeah a lot of
people don't a lot of people Coast
and it's good to have friends that
remind you of that like they're a friend
you have to have friends that remind you
where the bar is you know where it's
like
you got a lot of work to do still don't
[__] relax when I was 50 I I did my
my special complicated apes and I and I
it was like I I drew a line through
everything I'd come to LA to accomplish
like I was like okay the TV show all
that stuff you know and I remember just
I had this for about five minutes I had
this feeling of satisfaction I was like
oh you know everything
and then I was like well I'm eating too
much I'm eating out out too much and I'm
[__] looking for ways to get into
trouble this is bad there's no such
thing as drawing all of my lines to all
your goals you gotta you gotta just
figure it out you gotta keep standards
great because it's always it's always a
challenge you got to come up with new
[__]
do you ever feel like you're repeating
yourself
you mean old material no but like like
same theme you ever find like you're on
a same track and you try to get off it
does that ever happened to you because
that happened to me and then I had that
kind of [__] sometimes but you know I'm
always constantly writing you know
always every day you know I have a
system that I write and um so I'm always
trying to stay you know like now I have
all this Vietnam material what's your
system
how I do it
I have my phone and then I go blah blah
blah and do it whatever the the idea is
which is always in my mind and I send it
to vaseline on chin space yeah
and then I uh it goes for voice text to
my assistant and then he types it up and
organizes it slug chunk slug chunk which
is the slug is the concept and the chunk
is the joke and I just put it down there
and then it's Michelangelo time so then
I put it up on the big screen like that
he types every one of my assistant types
at least 90 words per minute really fast
so then I just I have him read it the
only way I can write is if I hear him
read it because when he reads it I it
tells me if it's funny or not because I
can hear it I can't write by myself I
hear it and then I'm like no no no yes
yes and I just keep michelangeloing the
bit boom boom boom boom boom and then I
get it to a place and then as an actor I
try to learn the bit and then when I get
on stage it's 50 percent that 50
improvise you know what I mean did you
ever that's really cool
Michelangelo I love that because do you
ever hear
um what he said if you read The Agony
and the Ecstasy it's about his life and
when he looked at the piece of marble
you know before he carved the statue of
David he apparently Legend says that he
he said to I think Beatrice's girlfriend
he said
it's in there it already exists
I just got to get all the I got to get
all this stuff out of the way yeah you
know it's kind of a cool way to look at
it like it already exists I've just
gotta I've got to get all the stuff that
doesn't belong around it right now out
of it and this it's a beautiful way of
looking at like the Joker the perfect
joke's already there for you in there
yeah you got to just like that's a I
never that's a really cool way to write
it I've been doing it for years wow
every one of my assistants has to type
at least 90 words per minute how many
assistance do you [__] have a lot why
because I don't like to hammer one
person
oh I like people to have their own lives
so everyone's part-time oh wow you know
what I mean but I wean people in my
system and my system works you know what
I mean my system works because I do
everything how do you find good
assistance I go
um I go online to there's different
websites and I basically have them
um do a two-minute video of why they
should be my assistant
and what their dreams are for themselves
and also they do a screenshot of a
typing test and it has to be at least 90
words per minute so you see that the
screenshot which is 90 words per minute
and you see the video and you see their
authenticity versus they're not
authenticity and you see if you want to
be with that person because at the end
of the day I want to help this person
and I want to support this person so
they can go off and learn and they can
go off and do stuff but I also want to
be able to be excited to be I have an
assistant right now who's working at my
house is banging out a whole bunch of
[__] and his name's Adam he's a really
good guy he's been with him about four
or five months and he's awesome and I
shift a lot to do a lot of different
things sometimes scripts sometimes uh
you know uh videos you know what I mean
it's always like different different
things sometimes it's a stand up
sometimes it's marking sometimes it's
travel sometimes it's you know what I
mean so you learn everything with me wow
yeah yeah I do it all that's so cool man
I like to you know I have a long line of
assistance that have gone off to do
great stuff yeah
and do you tell him you're probably sure
yes and do you do they know they're
gonna they know that it's the job to
work for Pauly Shore correct do you are
you on any dating apps
um yes and and uh what's your profile
picture
um I don't know it's just a photo
yeah I don't know what's your what do
you say in your bio
um hey buddy no I say can you type 90
words per minute no
um I don't know I don't remember it's
Raya do you know what right yeah yeah so
I never been on a dating app but yeah
and it's and it's it's mostly I I don't
think I've ever really hooked maybe here
and there over the years but it's mostly
just
you know
talking like this and not really talking
like this yeah a lot which is fine
whatever I guess it's you know weird
you know but it is what it is it's
technology
it's changing of the times it's the way
the world is now they're gonna come up
with unbelievable sex robots from what I
hear in about 10 years
yeah well they're doing that with
everything else I mean if you I mean it
started with the kiosk at the airport
you used to go to the airport and
there'd be someone there [__] the kiosk
though no
I mean you can't I mean you could I had
like a glory hole and a curtain
horny
step right up and then you go to
supermarkets and now there's no checkout
person you check out your own [__] yeah
but then there's always somebody because
there's always a malfunction
yeah but they're still trying to get
that that person out yeah but they know
they have to keep them there I know but
at some point they'll be like sorry you
gotta figure it out or you can't have
that sandwich yeah well they have they
have cashiers now where you have your
food tray and there's a camera that
looks at all of it instantaneously and
then just gives you what you owe so
you know all of this convenience is fine
it doesn't it's still you still left
with the problem of meaning how do you
have meaning in your life I mean it's
all good
but if you take away all the struggle
then I guess you have time to kind of
contemplate things I don't know
I sometimes I get tired of all the well
that's because we're older yeah you know
the younger people it's normal I mean
you see the kids come out they're in
their stroller they're holding an iPad
so true I mean that's just the way you
know that but we've we've at least got
to experience the thing that's really
crazy to me is
the 70s 80s 90s early 2000s were all the
same except for the Styles yeah music
change blah blah but it was pretty much
the same and then once the internet came
everything I mean it's such a big shift
you know what I mean it's such a big
shift the last 10 years
um well now ai will be the next shift
you know what's the AR artificial
intelligence oh got it yeah that that's
going to be the next shift yeah you know
and then you like you said there are
going to people that just not only they
grew up in it
but I think the shift after that will be
us meshing with machines that's going to
be you know for us it's going to be a
horror show but for them it's going to
be normal
you know
I don't know
it's really interesting because privacy
becomes impossible
and is that good
go to Vietnam
yeah are they technologically advanced
yeah of course yeah they all have it
yeah they all have yeah I got a massage
for three dollars from a blind guy what
three dollars it's called dong
that's the name of their their money
it's called Dong Dong yeah
no just dong it was a massage from a
blind guy on my birthday how was it
awesome it's [__] amazing yeah well
the difference well the difference
between massages overseas or in East
Asia and here is that's their world like
they really get into it they're not like
you know they're on their way somewhere
else what they're not on their way
somewhere else it's like in France the
waiter that's their career yeah they're
into it's not like they're um an actor
and I'm a murderer it's like there's
something really cool about that so um
but um yeah what would you be if you
were in a comic do you think or an actor
a street dancer in Paris
a mime Marcel Marceau yeah dude I feel
like you're in a box right now that's a
wall
so good yeah do you miss Mad TV no
too much work it was too much work it's
a lot of work I suck at work like it's a
lot oh dude you'd sit around in a room
and you'd debate whether monkey or
[__] was a funnier word and there'd be
fights that would break out and I don't
have that attention it was great yeah
yeah but I I I when you played the pool
anything funny that was that I did in
that show I'm not responsible for I
would show up and because the writers
were better than I was everybody else
was way more experienced and in my
opinion funnier and more talented yeah
this was the they they wrapped me down
yeah they I shaved my body because they
they would put this Tanner on and it
would make everything look so dark right
yeah yeah this was fun Joe Rogan and I
look at that first time that was the
first time we met wow where's me on
there I was on there with you did we do
a sketch yeah we did pool boy together
you were earlier twice that's funny yep
weird
what a [__] world dude
yeah I wish I was more muscular
thicker I always wanted to be bigger you
look pretty buff though no you're in
good shape whatever buff
looks like I look like a dancer
yeah that was all right
there he is
look at look at me
young man
I had a lot of gay I got a lot of gay
fan mail and and of course fan mail from
prison for real I believe it they all
wanted pictures
um and then I I knew do you wonder what
you wonder why well I went I went to uh
yeah I mean I know I understand but I
was a twink I was a twink and I went to
[__] um I went to a gay bar with my
buddy Jimmy Burke in New York City with
uh his girlfriend and I was just there
with him
and uh I was Elvis wow one guy was like
I'm sorry like uh you and I was like
yeah
[__] Elvis oh God hey then I went
I've been I've been to a couple gay bars
I went to the gay bar The Abbey and I
was standing there looking around I was
there with uh some people one was a big
agent and uh and I'm just standing there
looking around I hadn't seen this a lot
of dudes with their shirts off and some
guy comes up and goes you're straight
aren't you and I go
yeah and he goes figures and I was like
how the [__] did you know I was just
standing there I was giving off Straight
Energy
then I [__] him so
I like your glasses too
Venice Beach Pro four dollars really
[__] yeah how often do you go down there
what's your favorite part of that like
where do you go
you're so Hollywood
my favorite part that's what's great
about La it's it's broken up into so
many different Burrows did you grow up
in the valley no I grew up in West
Hollywood okay yeah no I'd have to say I
like silver like the best because I like
Silver Lake Ramen yeah which is amazing
um I also like uh I'm starting to like
the valley like Radford Ventura that
area I also like um
you know West Hollywood's cool you know
West Hollywood they are so different I
don't like any of those places yeah well
it's too much for me I don't know why I
never did
good ramen what would you what would be
your last meal
that looks good dude my last meal sushi
yeah probably Sushi really I Love Sushi
yeah what's your favorite I go to this
spot with Nicholas Cage uh it's called
Osaka and it's on Sahara and uh in um in
Vegas It's [__] amazing they had the
best Toro that's the that's the greatest
part about about um about living in Las
Vegas amazing unlike anyone else I've
learned all the cool spots off the strip
oh really yes really there's so many
killer spots off the strip wow yeah
there's the comedy club there now too
have you played it I have Wise Guys I
loved it yeah you own that with Keith
right I don't yeah well I'm I helped him
put it together yeah yeah so yeah Keith
stubs yeah so that's a great room I love
that room yeah so old school room yeah
yeah small but intimate and strong you
know
that's great yeah Vegas I have a
love-hate relationship with Vegas I you
know I like staying at uh
The Encore yes you know yes
there's something about it and I love I
like eating for me any place that has
good restaurants I'm good yeah no I'll
send you some really good spots for
Vegas next time Osaka give me another
Osaka I don't know there are a lot of
there's a place called Sparrow and wolf
which is on Spring Mountain [__]
amazing Sparrow sparrow and wolf so good
p-a-r-r-o-w yes
yeah Sparrow wolf it's amazing amazing
it's all fresh all from there wow and
then there's another place called
Esther's kitchen yeah that looks good
dude yeah look at those [__] drinks
dude I mean it's like legit it's all
fresh it's all like made there I mean
the bread's made there you know
everything's like that Esther's kitchen
is amazing
which is another great spot this is in
the arts district
no that's where Esther's kitchen is Yeah
man so that's right next to um uh yeah I
like that I like that area
it's kind of new right yeah like yes
well that's the thing Vegas has its own
Community it has nothing yes correct
yeah the industry it's like the industry
all the people that work the clubs they
live off the street yes yeah
so yeah I am leaving Vegas I'm moving
back to West Hollywood
um and then from there I don't know
where I'll go I'll be West Valley for a
bit and then maybe move to the valley I
don't know really yeah will you retire
will you die in L.A you think
if I want to stay in Show Business the
rest of my life then I'll probably stay
here if I um I think you will stand sure
yeah I think I think I'm gonna be like
George Burns
yeah you know just be doing stand-up
yeah
you're not doing that yeah what the [__]
am I gonna do yeah I love my kids though
I like that They Don't Love You No when
they get older they don't know yeah when
they're babies it's fine when they're
older like my son's already like almost
12 he doesn't give a [__] like he's I
love my favorite thing is teaching them
how to box and do [__] like that but but
he's uh you know he's gonna take it
their own lives they got school they got
all kinds they're humans they're humans
too yeah and they don't want to be
around you they don't want to be careful
about telling them what to do
my son gets annoyed he's like Dad I get
it but I'm like I want to hang out with
you all the time
you know but when they're babies it's
great that's why I said you should have
a kid when you're 70. I know you're
sorry because then you're on your
deathbed and all of a sudden like how
you write your assistant uh a program
and having a kid at 70 are the three
most genius things I've ever heard
I think it's the move yeah because like
yo I guess I can't help you I'm dying
yeah I'm an old man I don't know man I
want to help you get a good run yeah I'm
sorry 100 by the time you're 15 I will
not be here yeah study hard exactly
figure it out and they say when you lose
a parent when you're young sometimes it
can be the best thing they did something
like like all the world leaders
um lost at least one parent before the
age of 12. so wow yeah wow it makes
sense though it's like Quincy Jones did
you see that documentary on Quincy Jones
I think so nobody was he's incredible
his mother was taken away she was a
schizophrenic she was taken away from
her at seven years old oh wow he was on
the street his dad was always working
and you know black when his grandmother
was a slave man
born slave so he grew up you want to
talk about racism that dude but music
was the one thing he could control
you know that's like for me like
whenever no matter how bad things again
I think about stand-up I can start
writing
well definitely it's the for me it's the
most most comfortable place for me me
too it's to be on that stage and just I
can breathe me too you know what I mean
it's just like you know what I mean I'm
not nervous people are always that you
get nervous I go no this is where I want
to be all the time yeah so give me an
audience and if I don't have an audience
I'll the one thing I realized is like
being on sets of films or TV it was a
captive audience it was it was the
acting got in the way but I would have
people there I could [__] stick with
this dick and a God forbid I did uh I
did a [__] in Las Vegas or CSI or
something with uh Gilbert Gottfried oh
uh we spent a week together oh my God oh
my God all he like he loved to play
stick yeah he loved to be he'd love to
be sticky that's it
and uh like we would do a word
association game no matter what you said
I'd be like snowflakes you go I go just
whatever comes to your mind it goes
whatever it comes to my mind I go yeah
just okay just whatever I go yeah
snowflakes
puppies black [__] I was like no hold on
maybe I'm thinking about it too much no
matter what you said we'd do that bit
and we we beat it into the ground
he died did you know him well
I mean I knew him from back in the MTV
days we did a lot of stuff together but
I wouldn't wasn't you know what I mean
yeah I didn't spend a lot of time with
him though but anybody you didn't like
I feel like you got along with everybody
um or he didn't stick around long enough
to have real get into real because
that's how I was I never really
because I had guys a dick and I was like
I never saw it
yeah I think that if anyone that I
didn't like I wouldn't say their name
because it's like they were a piece of
[__] and like why even bring them up
yeah
you know what I mean like I feel that
way people you know and then they come
around and apologize for being a piece
of [__] yeah like oh you know like 10
years ago and I was I was going through
them so I'm like I love you it's all
good same way like I forgive you
everything like like the people are you
know people have moments or they get
outside of themselves or they they're
wounded yeah I had a thing with Al
magical really which was hilarious I
haven't talked to Alan a long time but I
like Al what happened and then I just
brought I brought him on stage not
perfectly yeah in the main room and he
got mad yeah he approached me after the
show like [__] like really yeah Al
doesn't [__] around yeah but he's also a
guy if you say sorry he'll be like
that's fine yeah and then we hugged it
out and I love him he's right he said he
was going through stuff or I'm like I
don't care but that's how Al's a great
guy I was not I was a guy who will do
who will
like he's honest I like Al because he's
super honest
you know and he doesn't mince words like
I feel that you know but
yeah I I don't if so I you know it's
funny
if people have said something or
whatever I always feel like well first
of all if they're saying that they don't
know me or they have they have a skewed
idea of who I am right or or they're
just having a bad time and I'm in the
way
a lot of times unfortunately
we as people if we're going if we're
stressed or we're not happy and then you
bring it into this then and they start
speaking about something and you're an
[__] to them it has nothing to do
with them it has the fact that you
brought in stuff from work you know or
if not work from personal life into work
yeah and that happens so it's about
shifting shifting is really important I
use that word a lot
um you know to say yeah shift you know
you have to shift because you're walking
into an environment with these guys that
are here for you and what happened out
there is what happened out there and
they're giving you gear they're giving
you their time and they're they're here
so you have to be respectful yeah yeah I
find myself as I get older not getting
mad as much like I like if somebody's
being a just um like somebody is
just doing something bad or just you
know or somebody's being a dick in
general or somebody's lashing out
like look what a lot of times you'll see
like somebody will be doing something
and you're like damn you know they're
they're and you go but but you look at
their life and you go man I wouldn't
want to be that person that's got to be
tough I might behave that way too if I
was that person if I was making those
choices and my life it comes yes there's
nice people come to us the realization
they're a certain age and they go holy
[__] I don't have a resume or whatever
it might be yeah and then they try to
they try to attack the existence
and there's also that guy that
just constantly constantly complains
about everything and he's he does it so
much he doesn't know he's doing it oh
man like I met I I work out at this gym
in Vegas complaining is blaming too yeah
you're blaming others yeah there's this
gem that I work out in Vegas called lvac
and there's this guy there he's pretty
crust he's you know gotten bullet holes
and shots and you know what I mean he's
just been through a lot but he's just in
that full-on like life is this and you
know what I mean he's that guy so it is
what it is yeah that's you know and you
agree with it you're like yeah I know
bro I get it as opposed to like do well
that's chaos whenever I see somebody
whose life is chaos or their energy is
chaos I get the [__] away from them I
used to be drawn into it now like the
one thing that Rogan's biggest strength
is knowing who's chaos and who's order
he knows who [__] is is is thrashing
in the water and it's going to take you
under if you get too close that dude
will be like oh [__] that guy's chaos by
he I've seen it a thousand times he'll
just he'll he'll walk in and go who the
[__] is that guy he reads things on
people he's like why is that guy that
way what's happening what's up with that
guy that guy get away from that guy he's
always right and I'm always like nah you
know it's fine that's why he always
pushes me out of the room when I come in
he's like get him out of here
get him out of here this has been good
thank you I'm glad I'm glad what his
name what's his name I don't even know
his [__] name your co-host
um wait I have one last time
his name is we call him shopping had a
message because you know obviously we
want to put his business out there he
couldn't make it for a reason yeah so he
made sure to say uh tell Polly I love
him he's always been good to me and his
Wise Guys club in Vegas is one of my
favorites awesome you want to make sure
that you heard that perfect perfect he
loves you dude yeah no I I'm very happy
for him yeah you know I'm very happy for
him the best yeah
um if you I'm gonna ask you one last
question then you can get out of here if
you could go back in time and ask
yourself tell yourself something
if you could go back right now and tell
your 20 year old self something what
would you say
um
well it's hard to say because I've made
a lot of choices based on my heart and
not my head
and sometimes I would say I would say
probably say make more choices based on
your head and not your heart but my mom
has always made her choices based off
her art and not her head and I got that
from her you'd probably make a different
kind of mistake
yeah and
you know with my career you know
um
sometimes it's better just to shut the
[__] up and even though you're it's
frustrating to kind of like I don't want
to say play the game
but just be a little bit more back you
know what I mean like you know I'm an
animal you know and I need to be free
but sometimes that's not right too
sometimes you got to play the game and
be cool in in in in operate cooperate
and and I don't know if it's called the
game but it's called just play the
business and
um provide your time you know what bide
your time because it's something called
sacrifice because you're bargain with
the future like it's like I'll do this
now because I know it's going to pay off
later that idea yeah I just think that
um
you know my managers and agents that
represented me back in the day were
amazing people
really good guys
um loved them and and they tried you
know and but I needed to be away here
and maybe here I shouldn't have
you know maybe I should have said hey
you know just take a break I don't need
to work right now like you know I love
you guys not like get rid of everyone
right and I and I think that
um that put me in a different it put me
in a different chorus or a path am I um
in my career and um and uh you know I
took things very personal
you know as opposed to saying oh this is
just the business like I had an awesome
run and uh um but again you know based
off of my heart as opposed to my head
and I think if anyone's gonna learn from
it this this podcast or this experience
that I've gone through I'm older is
sometimes it's good to like check
yourself and
um
and uh make your decisions based off
your head and not your heart
um but it's hard
you know what I mean yeah it's hard
especially when you're young and you're
all heart and no head yeah right yeah
[__] yeah I think I'd probably
am I right or I mean yeah I think I
agree with you on that yeah
I I think I I would agree because you
get like this thing yeah and I don't
know it's a weird thing right
it's a really weird thing because you
you know I would say key and don't lie
to yourself key into what's actually
what you actually honestly Revere but
sometimes you don't know until you do it
so sometimes you have to make these
mistakes otherwise it's called shifting
into a being a more of a professional
situation as opposed to being a personal
not taking it personal beat yeah oh go
back to business that might be why
manners and protocol are so important in
a lot of cultures you know like I feel
like like in a lot of cultures uh it's
like being being reserved and polite and
never losing your cool uh in public for
example or with in professional
relationships is is Paramount you're
taught that from a very young age right
very young yes yeah that would be like
certainly if you were Korean or Japanese
or English or whatever that's a that's
Paramount manners are [__] everything
and I didn't grow up with that enough
you there's another side to that which
is you as an American are allowed to
express yourself and say [__] this and
be kind of more John Mcenroe and not
Roger Federer or something I don't know
but it's also like it's a metaphor
terrible but it's also how you're raised
let me say that again let me let me say
it again it's how your raise and who
raises you I had no one raising me
okay my dad was not there my mom was
busy so I didn't have that Shaquille
O'Neal Father Phil who was a military
guy telling hitting the champion on the
[__] face going no [__] that's not
how it's done I don't think that would
have worked on you though because
because that works on kids that have a
personality that falls into that line
Creative Kids don't do well with that
kind of discipline necessarily yeah like
I I don't know I think you would have
grown to hate whoever did that to you
yeah and yeah I never yeah I fought my
mom a lot yeah yeah you know already a
free spirit you were already somebody
who was like I don't want to do it the
way normal people do
and that that a lot of times is what you
get when you have you need a certain
amount of neurosis maybe a certain
amount of anxiety a certain amount of uh
a wild sort of like um
self-destructiveness to be creative I
think sometimes I really do I think
sometimes to be creative you got to be
[__] a little out of control even
with yourself you know yes and that's
what I was yeah yeah and that's what you
want people to like you so badly that's
that was my thing is I just wanted
people to like me no matter what yeah
because because of my trip maybe the way
I grew up you know yeah but I didn't
have like like
I didn't have that
person to sit down with to be like hey
I'm at a Crossroads so your mom and dad
wouldn't be that person when you would
ask they were busy wow you know they
were busy you know what I mean and I'm
not saying they weren't there for me but
they were you know my mom had her
passion which is The Comedy Store and
The Comedians and my dad was on the road
yeah you know what I mean what about
your older brothers
um
no I mean
they were off doing their own thing you
know my family's weird we're all kind of
like in our own Yeah in our own place
you know my one brother's in Portland my
brother's San Diego you know I'm you
know what I mean it's really interesting
yeah and it's like we're all in our own
kind of sphere or atmosphere or whatever
so
but
I think it just goes back to looking in
the mirror
and and making decision based off your
heart versus your head with your head
you could stop and kind of check
yourself and be like wait a minute and
then you know what I mean as opposed to
this which is like this
you know when you know you're getting
[__] over you know things are [__]
you kind of react off of this yes it's
kind of like drugs yeah you know what I
mean it's like you know like I've
partied before but I've never partied
before I've never pulled the all the
Charlie Sheen all-nighter four day thing
and I think that's this
do you know what I mean not like this or
I'm like let's keep go this is awesome
let's you know you know what I mean yeah
like even with partying with Kennison
you know he was that guy that would go
for four or five days you know he was
that guy and I just was never that guy
um and that's because of this yeah it
wasn't like oh I want to be with Sam
Kennison and I'm gonna [__] go for
four days just like him I never did I
just didn't have the Constitution I'm
just a [__] if I drink two glasses of
whiskey the next day I'm like I can't
for a week right you know yeah so it's
not even discipline it's just that I'm
more delicate
but it's interesting it's interesting
you know some some decisions we make in
life really affect I mean you look at
the guys that are in jail
you know that one that I mean you see
these shows that one little thing
[__] little thing man you know that
you know so you got to be really you
know whether it's your career whether
it's a relationship with a woman whether
it's a relationship with a family you
know whatever it is
um yeah I think somebody said who who
has made done all everything right and
it's got all the money and everything
and he said I used to think that the
most important thing for my kids was to
find out what you want to do with your
life and now I think the most important
decision they can make is who they
choose to marry or who they choose to be
with I never thought of that you know
and I agree with it that and that's what
I agree with
that's what I agree with I don't know I
mean you still make mistakes you can
still enter every relationship like with
a full heart and complete honesty and
still get burned or or it doesn't work
out or people change in the relationship
I don't know I I just think that in a
lot of ways like we're existentially
[__] maybe that's the point if you're
trying to be perfect or you're trying to
not make to not make mistakes that's
hilarious it's adorable
yeah because it's going to happen yeah
that might be why you and I when we saw
each other just now
uh had this Bond of intimacy I think
there's an understanding of that like
the competition is done I'm not trying
to win anything I'm just happy to see
you you're happy to see that you're
alive yeah and that you're still doing
what you're doing and I'm doing what I'm
doing and that that makes me feel good
that we've been on this journey you know
and strangers the night I would see you
if we touch points but I know what you I
I think part of being a comic when I see
a guy like you is I know a lot about
your life whether you know you know a
lot about my life just because we've
done the same thing for so long
and that's kind of cool
you know it's kind of cool
so Paulie story you're the best man
thank you for coming on yeah
it's awesome I adore you I adore you
yeah yeah and Brandon um where Are You
Gonna Be Where can we find you no I'm
just kidding yeah no Brandon again
missed you today but everything happens
for a reason I hope whatever is going on
your personal life it's all taken care
of and I'll see you next time and uh
everything's cool where are you gonna be
I'll be uh when is this air
tomorrow Thursday oh [__] okay yeah well
I will be in Atlanta
Atlanta I'll be at Comic-Con there
signing pictures next to Brandon Frazier
and Sean Aston francino man damn Encino
Man 2 the sequel and then uh no I'm just
kidding no I'll be there and then we'll
be at the I think it's called the the
Atlanta theater or something in Atlanta
what is it called Atlanta comedy theater
and then all the other shows are sold
out which is cool yeah all my other
shows are sold out good for you which is
cool which is awesome dating Funny Bone
you're also there's Fort Wayne I just
did Fort Wayne yeah the guys right I
loved it those guys are great they're
great yeah Adam yeah they're the best
yeah they run a great club dude oh yeah
all those you know what I heard it's
really good the blue room and uh I've
done it I've done it yeah amazing Chris
right I'm on text with him I gotta yeah
amazing yeah great great things about
that yeah
uh I'm in a comic strip in Edmonton
Alberta we are not sold now yeah let's
go February 23 24 25 Zanies March 2 3
and 4 in Nashville Tennessee Sony Hall
one show only March 11th New York City
come get some West Nyack New York Levity
Live March 16 to 18. I'll see you there
we're playing all the same spots I know
Naples Florida for Brendan's job
February 16 17 18 at off the hook Comedy
Club Bakersfield California February 23
Pasadena California
um February 25. uh he's got Brea
California March 3rd uh one show only
he's doing a lot of one shows Oklahoma
City Oklahoma The Summit Comedy Club the
same guys March 9 10 and 11. yeah
awesome yeah also uh yeah definitely go
check out Brian and Brandon when you're
out there support support Live Comedy
and all that let's have some [__]
laughs awesome in a band called polisher
on the crustace and we're going to be
polish on the crusties we're going to be
at the Sand Dollar
um on uh which is the club in Vegas on
March 14th and then I'll also be at
South by Southwest with my podcast
called uh jam and the van podcast hosted
by Pauly Shore and we'll be doing a show
out there there's my band The crusties
so you're doing the damn thing yeah so
great yeah those guys look at those old
guys yeah it's great yeah see look at
the Rocket Man guy look at that that's
Rocket Man right there see which one so
yes I've been in this band for a couple
years and we do shows around Vegas it's
pretty much called polisher on the
crusties and it's me with like a bunch
of senior citizens I know you could sing
well I can't that's the joke oh my God
but I commit like I can't do you sing
covers yeah I'll covers what like what
are your favorite covers well they're
all on there there's rape me there's by
Nirvana there's sabotage Old Man by Neil
Young
oh man yeah drop the bomb
you dropped the bomb home right yes so
we do these songs out of my garage in
Vegas oh my gosh um but yeah
well walk don't I mean run don't walk
yeah bad get those tickets Bad to the
Bone so March 14th and this is my kind
of send-off to Vegas because I'm Leaving
Vegas we just put in my 30-day notice uh
yeah 30-day notice today and I'm moving
behind the Commons Drive a house up
there and I'll be by the store I need to
be by my mom and by the club you know I
need to have the comics you're gonna be
down there a lot yeah nice yeah I love
Richie and Emily and all of them are
doing great over there and um you know
it's uh yeah for sure so all right kids
this has been Pauly Shore fighter and a
kid
[Music]